hey everybody it's Mike freeder here
with on call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control mp.
l238 do3 sanitize or destroy system
media contains cui before disposal or
release for
[Music]
reuse so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
the cmmc DS and NP 1on1 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's on
call compliance Hero Let's jump into it
so uh if you've talked about the idea
that you can't just send computers
copers and any other medium that
contains cui off for repair but now
we're talking about the end of life the
big goodbye walk in the plank at death
do you part with your computer equipment
in
n171 we have a clear directive that we
must sanitize must must must sanitize or
destroy any media that contains cui
before disposal by the way here's a hint
to my friends in manufacturing this
includes physical cui which could
potentially include scrap or quality
failed pieces that kind of thing all
right there's a lot to proper Data
Destruction program and if you need help
with that it's one of the many many many
policies we customize for our clients
when we work with them but before we get
carried away let's zero in on what the
assessors really want on this one how to
make them happy because we love making
assessors happy right all right
determine if system media containing cui
is sanitized or destroyed before
disposal uh this is Implement C Data
Destruction policy uh determine if
system media containing CI is sanitized
before it is released for reuse and of
course yes see the Data Destruction
policy because you can't really give it
demonstration of something that's been
erased I think that's I think that's how
you do it yeah no yeah that's how to do
it that's what the assessors passed us
on uh so hey at on call guess what we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this dears nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped in
their laps like a seagull on a sunny day
baby we teach you how to level up and be
a proper on call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on call
compliance hero can do for you uh if
you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
compliance seekers.com or check out the
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better Hulk smash that subscribe
button baby uh and make sure you get
those alerts okay these standards change
a lot there's a lot going on uh and
again we want to make sure to get you
the latest inred stuff until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next
[Music]
one